Okay so
this should now be live let's see if we
ask people
hello everyone
okay so now I'll just mention this
another Discord
foreign
cool so we've got a few people here um
maybe we can um uh give a few minutes
before we actually start the
presentation
um but uh you know while we're getting
started maybe
um Moshe and Aaron would you like to
introduce yourselves
okay I'm Orin uh part of the uh set fit
uh project working at intelabs NLP team
um
yeah
[Music]
I'm leading the NLP team at the inter
lab as part of this project
[Music]
looking forward in exciting
great thank you and uh for everyone else
I'm Lewis from hugging face I work
primarily on the open source team and
I'm also been very excited to be working
with my share Luke Aaron and others on
making
uh future learning actually work in the
real world
cool so we've got a few people
um we're just tuning in
um
what do you reckon shall we just start
and then people I think can later
um uh you know watch the Youtube
recording what do you guys reckon
so we start Swiss style we start on time
cool so this um
this talk or this presentation today
um is primarily about
um how to do future learning efficiently
I'm using a special type of Transformer
model called sentence Transformers
and this is work done together with
Intel labs and ukp in Germany
um and it's basically broken down into
sort of three things you can check out
after this talk we have a paper which
goes into a lot of the sort of
nitty-gritty details on how this
technique works and shows lots of
different experiments we ran to compare
against other methods but if you want
just a high level summary you can check
out the blog post which gives a more
conceptual understanding of what happens
under the hood and finally if you want
to actually use the methods that we
discussed today we have a library called
set fit on GitHub that you can pip
install and run in collab
so let's get started
and switch my thing okay so what we'll
do today is um I'm going to start by
talking a little bit about you know what
what is future learning uh why is it
important and how does the set fit
method work and then we'll dive into a
bit of a Hands-On demo with the separate
library to sort of show you how it works
in action
and finally we'll leave some time for a
question and answering our session and
if you have any questions
um during the talk
um please feel free to put them in the
YouTube chat and we'll take um you know
the questions as they come so that it
doesn't just uh you know become me
speaking into a into a screen outside
so with that other way
Let's uh start by talking a little bit
about future learning and a few short
learning in particular with language
models
so I think this is a fairly kind of old
uh let's say idea
um it's it's not just been around the
last few years but um in some sense I
think it was the arrival of gpt3 by
openai that really popularized this idea
of what future learning entails and in
their paper the gpt3 they described
future learning as basically a way of
describing a natural language some tasks
providing a few examples of what that
task looks like and then finally getting
the model to basically auto complete
um the the prediction from that prompt
and so you can see here
um in this example
um if you start by specifying the task
as a translation task so you say
translate English to French
and then you give some examples like sea
otter and that's looted in there and
peppermint is meant
then the idea is that if you provide
enough of these examples
at the end when you translate cheese you
hopefully get the the correct French
translation
and this particular type of future
learning it's called if you shop because
you're only providing a few examples but
it's specifically it's called in context
learning because in the case of gpt3
there are no gradient updates performed
on the model so this is really just an
inference time
uh sort of form of prediction
and what they showed in the paper is
that um if you look at the performance
um of across many different types of NLP
tasks with gpd3 as you increase the size
of the model you start to see
um rather big gains in the future regime
so you can see in this plot on the right
that when you're dealing with like you
know a few hundred million parameters
your kind of average accuracy across
many different tasks is like 30 but then
as you scale this up to 175 billion
parameter model you're now looking at an
average score of you know a bit closer
to 60. so that's a fairly non-trivial
gain
um but of course that game isn't for
free so the the kind of two main
problems or challenges with this in
context learning is that first of all
you need to come up with a good task
description and some good examples
um that the model was able to use
appropriately
and this often leads to problems where
the performance of the model depends on
the choice of prompt so if you're on
Twitter you may see every now and then
people coming up with very clever
prompts for example it's recently been
shown that if you want gpt3 to do high
order reasoning about say science
problems if you just add the prompt
let's think this step by step it will
then iteratively you know generate a
much better solution and so this kind of
sensitivity to the type of prompt is a
bit of a challenge
and of course the other like more
practical challenge is trying to
actually deploy 175 billion parameter
model isn't really a super easy task and
in general it's basically prohibitive if
you want to actually you know use these
techniques on edge devices or any sort
of you know smaller Hardware
so although this is uh definitely a very
interesting phenomenon and very
promising it has these kind of two
limitations
so of course many researchers have uh
worked on trying to you know reduce the
size of the models and to to make this
idea more efficient
and one of the like most popular ones in
recent years is something called pattern
exploiting training
um or pet and a more recent variation
called adipet which makes it uh you know
a little bit easier to train
and the basic idea of these pattern
exploiting training methods is that
instead of doing everything with a kind
of in-context prompt like in gp3 what if
we could convert the thing that we're
interested in classifying for example
best pizza ever
into a format that was more similar to
the language modeling task of the
underlying model so if we think about
models like Bert and all the sort of
masked language modeling Mass language
models that we have
one way we could think about this is
that we just take a input and then we
just append a little piece of text where
we try to get the model to fill in the
blank so you can see here if we give
best pizza ever then if we just append
something like it was blank then the
master language model uh presumably will
have a pretty good chance of filling in
that the most likely token for that is
great
and then if we have that we can then
Define a mapping which converts uh you
know the positive or negative labels to
the um you know vocabulary that's
present in the in the language model so
you can see in this kind of example here
end to end we provide a piece of text we
get the language model to fill in some
template and then based on that output
we try to assign a score
and this um this method Works uh quite
well um you can see in this plot here
um with adipet which is an improved
version of pet
um that they're able to actually surpass
the performance of gpt3
um on the super glue benchmark
um and also using
um you know a very small fraction of
task specific data so
one of the challenges in the original
pet proposal was that you had to provide
a lot of specific training data of a
given task you know framing things in
terms of let's say text classification
and adipat was able to kind of do away
with that and actually do get quite good
performance
but you can see that we have a similar
kind of problem that we mentioned with
gpt3 so here you instead of having to
create task descriptions and explicit
examples you have to craft a prompt
template so we have to come up with lots
of these different ideas of how do we
append things for the language model to
fill in
and the other challenge is that because
the we need a way of mapping
um the labels to the vocabulary of a
language model
these things are called verbalizers and
they tend to have kind of variable
lengths of how we do that and this means
that it's typically very slow to train
we can't typically train these models
using batching and a lot of the kind of
implementations like add a patent pad
typically use batch size one which makes
it quite slow to train if you're using
something like you know an Albert or a
Roberto large model as your backbone so
although the performance is good we do
have this kind of intrinsic dependency
on organism transplantations
so the most recent
um attempt to to make things more
efficient and um a bit less uh well a
bit faster to train and so on
um is something called a parameter
efficient fine-tuning
and this is an idea which actually goes
back a few years
um to this idea that instead of having
to retrain or fine-tune all of the
parameters in a language model
what if we could find a way to insert
some special layers which are
conventionally called adapter layers
um into the network itself and then we
essentially just train
um the the weights of those adapter
layers while leaving the vast majority
of the network untouched
and this idea of using adapters it's
basically just injecting a couple of
feed forward networks
um inside your Transformer layers
and this has been used
um in a wide range of applications from
things like multilingual transfer if you
want to convert a model that has been
say trained in English German
translation and you want to extend it to
French you can try to use these adapters
to to improve the generalization to new
languages
um but more recently a research team
with Colin raffle and others in the US
they propose something called tfue and
what tfue does is it basically combines
this idea of using adapter layers and a
kind of efficient training regime for
them together with um a multi-task model
called t0 which is uh something that was
trained as part of the big science
project
and the idea here is that this t0 model
is a language model very similar to gpd3
but it's been trained on many different
tasks in parallel and so the idea here
is that if we can find ways to
efficiently update certain layers or
these adapter layers inside t0 then we
might be able to do few short learning
across many different tasks
and so what they show here in their
paper is that um tifu
is not only more performant than gpt3
um it's also far more efficient so this
plot is showing essentially the the
average accuracy across a range of
different data sets they they
benchmarked and on the x-axis you have
the the flops
um per example so this is basically
showing that for inference tfue is
around one and a half to two orders of
magnitude more efficient than gpt3 so
this is a great step forward in having
both high quality models but also the
ones that are faster to train and run
but again because it depends in this
particular case on t0 which has this
kind of language modeling component you
do have to do a fair amount of prompt
engineering and when we ran our own
experiments in the set fit paper we also
found that we had to spend a fair amount
of time coming up with clever prompts to
adapt this type of approach to new data
sets and that's kind of a bit too close
to you know labeling your own data and
it feels a little bit like you know
we're not quite solving future learning
uh in a kind of you know generic way
and the other thing is that the
performance of this model tends to also
depend on having a sort of large sort of
10 billion parameter model and just for
context this is around you know 12
gigabytes or 11 gigabytes on your disk
space so if you wanted to ever deploy
such a thing on you know a phone or
whatever it's going to be quite a
struggle to make this work so although a
great step forward still we have some
limitations here
so the main thing that
um I think Moshe probably was the first
one to ask himself is you know can we do
better
um than you know depending on prompts
depending on large models and depending
on a lot of this kind of like feature
engineering uh approach to Future
learning
and the the answer is uh yes we can do
that
um and there's a proposal that we have
in our paper called set fit which stands
for sentence Transformer fine-tuning
and this uh idea is remarkably simple it
basically breaks down
um say something like text
classification into a two-stage training
recipe
and the first stage involves
first adapting a pre-trained sentence
Transformer
to learn how to handle essentially this
new set of small labeled examples and
we'll see more details of that in a
second but basically this relies on
using contrastive learning to learn Rich
representations of the label data
and then once we've adapted that
sentence Transformer we can then use the
embeddings from it essentially as
features to a classification head which
then we can just train in a standard
fashion so in in the paper we just use
something very simple just logistic
regression but in principle this could
be just a neural layer with some classes
so this is essentially the the idea and
um we've shown in the paper that it
works quite well for text classification
um and other ideas in for example total
classification we're currently
investigating so just keep in mind that
what I'm telling you today is mainly
about text classification
um but you know maybe in the not Tuesday
future we'll have a similar approach for
other tasks
and if you have any questions just uh
please put them in the YouTube and I'll
I'll um I'll answer them whenever they
arise
okay so let's uh dive in a little bit to
how these two stages of training work in
more detail
so I mentioned that we use contrastive
learning
um to adapt for sentence Transformer
and it's probably better to explain you
know what is contrastive learning using
computer vision uh because it's a little
bit more intuitive
so the basic idea of contrasted learning
is you want to kind of adapt your
network so that the resulting embeddings
um uh basically pushed into regions of
the feature space where
um sort of images or inputs that are
similar are clustered together and
images that are different from each
other are pushed away from each other
and so you can see in this example here
with a dog we start off with an image of
a golden retriever this is typically
called an anchor in the jargon but
that's not so important and the idea is
that okay
um this this might be have the class dog
and this other image here of an owl is
obviously a different animal so we might
have two classes dog and owl and what we
do is we basically encode all these
images together and then we measure the
distance between the embedding of dog
with a kind of just an augmented version
of itself and also the distance of dog
compared to the owl and so if we can
kind of develop a loss function that
will progressively minimize the distance
of similar dog images and push or
maximize the distance of dog to every
other type of energy this will help us
construct an embedding space where
constructing a decision boundary on this
for classification is much much simpler
than you know just starting from scratch
so what you can see on the right hand
side here is an example of what this
looks like in feature space so here
um this Theta is is the the network and
so if we pass for example Echidna we end
up at some place in this feature space
but you can see that for example raccoon
these two raccoon images are kind of
closer to each other and as we train we
expect that we will basically push these
raccoon embeddings closer and the
Echidna ones will go further away
and I see that there are a few questions
in the chat so they will take them now
the first one is
what if the pre-trained model is not
optimized by contrasted learning any
effect on that
so that's actually
um a good a great question
um one thing that we looked at in the
paper
um well I don't know if we put it
published in the paper but it's
definitely some experiments we did was
comparing the effect of using sentence
Transformer models which are in some
sense well suited for this contrastive
learning process versus standard
Transformer backbones so things like you
know bird distilled birth and I think
our own and watching can correct me but
I think from memory this tended to be
much better when we use sentence
Transformer backgrounds so there is an
effect depending on the pre-trained
model you choose but our advice would be
to to pick a sentence Transformer
I don't know if anyone if you can watch
your or and want to comment on that if
not I'll go to the next question
Okay so we've got one more question here
from Patrick is this something like what
word to VEC does for simple word
embeddings
okay in a sense you could say that
um this is a similar kind of approach uh
to word to VEC the main difference here
is that
um in word to VEC you're learning kind
of universal representations you know
one word has one unique um embedding
whereas in this case we're adapting the
embeddings
um according to the training data so the
analogy for NLP is that instead of
picking
like um dogs and owls we would have text
so we would have for example I love this
pizza and I hate this pizza so this is
now a positive and negative example and
then we're going to push those text
embeddings into different parts of the
feature space that make it easier to
classify
so let's see
I think I'll take the other questions as
we as we go beyond but um this is the
basic idea of contrastive learning
and the sort of kind of main question of
how do you integrate contrastive
learning
um in this uh text context is you know
how do we generate these positive and
negative uh samples
so the way we do this in the paper is
suppose I give you
um a list of sentences or texts so these
might be for example movie reviews that
you want to classify as positive or
negative
and each one of these texts has some
labels let's call them L1 to Ln
and so what we need to do is we need to
find a way of sampling from this list of
texts which ones are positive and which
ones are negative so that then we can
basically Define this distance function
between them
and the way we do this is we we
basically just randomly sample
um a sentence or a text and we know it's
labeled and then what we do is we select
another sample which has the same label
so the idea is that we're going to
create first a positive pair of two
sentences which have the same positive
label and then we play the same game
where we basically pick now a new sample
which has a different label to the one
we started with
and this will produce two kind of
triples or tuples so you're going to
have one which is like your positive one
with the Positive label and one which is
now a mix of a positive sentence and a
negative sentence with a negative label
and this is now something that you can
use in the standard contrastive learning
framework
and it has the effect of basically
changing the the sort of functionality
of the Transformer from being less about
um embedding sentences to now figuring
out how you get good kind of
representations of topics or you know
the domain of the classes that you're
interested in
could you uh move you're still
highlighting Patrick's question it's
it's crazy all right here we go no
worries
okay so just to just to sort of recap
what I was saying um we we basically
sample from the um the small number of
labeled sentences or texts that we have
uh positive examples and negative
examples and then we combine those to
then do the contrasted learning uh
process and this then produces something
analogous to this example here we're now
in the feature space all of the texts
that belong to a certain class will tend
to get kind of clustered together versus
those that are of different of a
different class
okay so let's see
do we have any more questions
okay so there's a question here from
from Yang which is
um is this because the training
objective between pre-training and
fine-tuning is consistent so the result
will be better so I think this was a
follow-up question to this idea of like
whether you should use a sentence
Transformer or a standard um you know by
encoder like Bert and I don't know maybe
Moshi would you like to share some
insight on like you know why do you
think that the sentence Transformer
models tend to perform better as the
backbone of the set food yeah I think
basically sentence and formers or is
also a pre-trained model that train on
more than one billion pairs of sentences
so
there is a good start of what is
similarity between sentences and
fine-tuning basically had the topic
information so it's creating the topic
embedding I think pre-training is kind
of something analogy to the Cross
encoder like birds which is uh also
pre-train on on MLM so in this case it
was trained on on similarity
um so I think it's a good uh pre-trained
model to do the topic similarity
uh versus the standard cross encoder
great thanks that's a great answer
so we actually have another kind of
related question about the contrastive
learning process from Mark which is have
you thought about using hard negative
examples for fine tuning instead of
random ones so here the idea is that
instead of looking that you specifically
look for samples that are close to your
positive sample in different class
so I don't know if you've ever ran this
experiment motion but um no I think I
think it would be uh it would be an easy
one it's a good idea
um
yeah the results that we'll show you
today were just done with random
sampling so if someone wants to do the
same experiments but now with hard
negative examples
um I have a kind of intuition that maybe
the performance would be slightly better
great question mark
and
is there another question here which is
I think a good one from vishwas which is
if you have multiple classes
um how is the selection of negative
classes done
so in in our paper we just used a random
sapling so the idea was that
um when I get my positive one that's
kind of clear I just pick another
example that has the same class but then
when I want to sample a negative one I
just pick
um one label that doesn't belong in the
step that I'm looking at
and I suppose one could think of
slightly more complicated things like
stratified sampling where you try to
make sure that you're picking a similar
amount of samples of the other classes
but at least in our sort of supplement
Plantation this um this seem to work
quite well
um
and
another question is maybe just worth
mentioning here quickly is um does this
work for multi-class multi-label and uh
yeah the answer is yes we have a
notebook in the repository which we can
quickly point you to after this
um where we started with just
multi-class but this was extended to
multi-label uh by the community so the
results are also quite quite compelling
and not only encourage you to check that
out okay
okay so this was the sort of in some
sense the real magic part of set fit
just comes down to this like contrasting
learning step because after this you've
now got a sort of fine-tuned transfer
sentence Transformer and then after that
it's just essentially doing standard
test classification and training ahead
so let's maybe
um look at sort of some of the
experiments that we did
um in the paper
so
um we compared uh set fit to a range of
different uh bass lines
um the the first one was the sort of
obvious one which is just fine-tuning
um a Roberta large model
um across all these different data sets
and we picked these data sets primarily
for like diversity so we look at things
like sentiment analysis
um kind of counterfactual reasoning
um like customer review classification
and motion detection and then topic
classification and what you can see here
is that when you've only got eight
labeled examples per class uh the
performance of your sort of standard or
vanilla Transformer is is usually quite
low except for some data sets like Enron
spam and AG news where you know but
perhaps this is kind of already an easy
data set to classify on but in general
you can see that the average performance
was around 43 percent
and then we compared other kind of let's
say current state-of-the-art methods so
one is called perfect
um which is a special technique uh that
adapts kind of like the the work that
was done at a pit in a clever way
um and then there's the tfu model that I
mentioned recently
um and in our paper we only were able to
run the three billion parameter model
but we've since then been able to run
the 11 billion promoter one and the
results are you know slightly better but
not significant so
so what you can see here is that
um although uh TPU performs
um really well as we can sort of expect
for an 11 or 3 billion parameter model
um on average uh sit fit does tend to be
competitive and when you've only got
late level examples so kind of an
average we're basically within one
standard deviation
um of TPU
um and then as this uh as you increase
the sort of number of label examples
that um you have then the the kind of
gap between TPU and uh set fit uh
shrinks so then you can see that uh once
we start doing this the sort of average
performance you know now instead of TQ
being ahead uh we end up being slightly
ahead
so these kind of results show that um
with like uh eight or 64 labeled
examples uh for some data sets you can
get reasonably close to fine-tuning on
the full Corpus so for example in sst5
um you're around maybe 10 points behind
an eight and then once you have 64
examples you get pretty close to the
full fine tuning and this is then you
know even clearer when we look at things
like
aging news or Enron spam
um but the you know the kind of hardest
ones at the moment are things like
counter factual reasoning
um where you can see that you know
there's still quite a gap to be closed
and this might be something that is just
simply nature of the task is very
difficult
um so in general you know set fit isn't
a silver bullet it won't you know
magically solve all of your business
problems but for many data sets it um it
does give a big boost compared to
standard functioning
and the other thing that we compared was
um sort of the the training and
inference times of set fit compared to
tview and here you can see in this plot
this is uh you know roughly what it
costs uh to train
uh tfue on um uh on a a100 versus
training you know set fit on the same
data sets
um uh on a sort of simple like T4 GPU
that you get on on collab
um and so you can see here that you know
although the performance between TPU and
set fit is not you know significantly
different it is roughly 30 times faster
to train uh
and in fact this is you know just the
three billion parameter models so if we
train the full 11 billion Crown model
then this number increases
and one of the things that's pretty
interesting is um you can actually even
run set fit on your laptop uh it takes
around 10 minutes or so uh to to sort of
train through uh these eight labeled
examples and you know that's one of the
things that we're very excited about is
that you can sort of do few short
learning really you know on your Mac and
you don't need to use you know large 80
gigabyte a100 gpus files
so
let's see oh we have a good question
from Chris which is
did you experiment with different sizes
of set fit how small can the sentence
Transformer be and still be performant
that's a really good question
um we looked at uh three sort of main
models in the paper one was the mpnet
model which is the results I'm showing
in this table we also looked at um a
model called all Roberta large which is
essentially a sentence Transformer uh
trained with uh Roberta large
architecture
um and we also looked at mini LM
sentence Transformer which is uh
significantly smaller
now what we found is that um mpnet is
kind of your general best all-rounder
this is around a few hundred megabytes
um and typically a few hundred million
parameters
um and if you go down to the mini LM
size where we're talking around 80
million parameters the performance drops
um by a few percentage points but
there's a technique that Aaron will show
us uh soon on how you can reduce that
Gap using knowledge installation
and there's a question here from
Jonathan some did you say 10 minutes of
training for future learning or 10
minutes that's for training so to train
a separate model typically takes around
10 minutes on on eight labeled examples
in my laptop
um and um the the inference itself is is
as fast as the sentence transformed
basically so you can optimize this using
uh you know various techniques
okay and we actually have a question
from matu about multilingual
Transformers and indeed we looked at
that so this is another thing that um is
quite convenient about using a sentence
Transformer Backbone in contrast to a
large pre-trained language model
um because now instead of having to come
up with prompts for
um all of the you know different tasks
and the different
um uh sort of labels that we want
what we can do is we can just switch the
pre-trained model for a multilingual
sentence Transformer and then run the
the algorithm again
so here we did experiments on something
called the multilingual Amazon review
Corpus where you've essentially got
Amazon reviews in several different
languages and they're all rated with
stars you know from one to five of sort
of how good those reviews are
and so what you can see
um these numbers they correspond to the
mean absolute error so smaller is better
and if we just do standard fine tuning
most of our scores are roughly in the
sort of 120 region
um and then using set fit you know
roughly improves that by around 60
um so we're not quite you know hitting
the the full fine tuning regime with
eight labeled examples
um but of course you could close that
Gap
um by increasing and adding more labeled
a few more labeled examples so this is
something that we were quite excited
about because it allows you to quickly
switch out to different languages
um and um
uh one of the things that um uh you know
I think is like kind of an open question
is like you know how do you handle very
very low resource languages
okay so now I'm going to give the
microphone over to the washing he's
going to show us something that we
didn't quite have a chance to cover in
the paper but it's also a quite a cool
technique so I'll let you tell us a
little bit about how we can actually use
the same method to do zero shot
classification
yeah so thank you Luis so yeah for those
shorts they actually don't have any
training data so instead of having a
trend data what we did is um add uh
basically a synthetic sentences
that describe the labels for example
um if it's a two uh sentence um
specification we had this sentence is
negative label zero and this sentence is
positive label level one that's it and
then we actually basically use the same
sets with trainer and you can see the
output of
the per generation you see that there is
um label one and label zero and you see
that label one is uh just uh two
sentencing the same two sentences
um and actually it's quite um remind us
the work by steam CSE presented by GAO
in MN repeat 21 this is also did some
unsupervised learning uh with the
sentence Transformer
and actually uh got very good results
uh so by just applying this trick we can
actually get a zero shot classification
and surprisingly it's actually
outperform uh for the standard spots
large NRI model that is used by
Transformers Pipeline and I will show
results in in the next slide and also
you can use this technique to augment
your futures learning so you can add the
uh uh sentences as as another as an
augmented data for the future of the
experiment and this is actually what we
see here uh the the in the upper
um graph we see the uh the uh last line
is uh plus Le which is uh adding the uh
the uh zero shot to the fuel shot and
you see uh quite nice Improvement uh for
some data set and it's really worth
trying adding just the uh it's very easy
to add the um the labels and the and the
data for this specific task also you see
the uh the other uh table is actually
comparison to the uh part Lodge mnli
which is uh 400 million parameters you
see quite nice Improvement
just using set Suite uh we deserve a
short experiment with just 100
um million uh format as you see a nice
Improvement here
um so it's actually worth trying just to
add
the sentences as an augmented data and I
will show an example if we have time how
you can run use this uh to run the
experiment
yeah next slide for uh
it's about more describing the
distillation uh no one will show the
destination part
okay let's talk uh briefly about the
distillation so uh Lewis showed that
such it is comparable with the
state-of-the-art view shot methods and
in our main experiments uh we use the
mpnet sentence Transformers backbone
this is uh the size of 110 million
parameters
and in this section a question was
whether we can use a much smaller uh
sentence Transformers
that can be even more useful and
practical in deployments
and for this purpose we tested the set
fit in a distillation setup
for the teacher we use the standard set
fit with the mpnet backbone
and for the students we use paraphrase
media lab
as a sentence Transformer backbone and
this student contains only 15 million
parameters
which is seven times smaller than the
the teacher model
so the first step of the distillation
setup was uh just to train the teacher
using 16 labeled samples per class this
is a standard set fit training
and then the next step you can see the
block diagram on the right here
was to train the sentence Transformer of
the student to mimic the sentence
Transformer of the teacher by minimizing
the loss between the student output and
the teacher cosine similarity
and for that we use pairs of
of sentences uh unlabeled sentences
the next step is uh
the standard step of training the
classification head of the uh of the
student but this time we use the
embeddings produced by the student and
the Logics produced by the teacher
so that's that was our distillation
setups
and you can see the results here there's
two uh kinds of results the first are
shown in the two graphs above here the
x-axis is the number of unlabeled
training data that we used and the
y-axis is the average accuracy
and the blue line is the set fit uh
student and the orange line here is the
uh set fit uh is the Baseline student
which is a standard Transformer that we
used
and what we can see here is that when we
use the a small number of unlabeled
training data there's a significant uh
um
that set with outperformed significantly
the the standard Transformer but the Gap
decreases when you have more unlabeled
data for training
so that was our first result
and then the table below shows a
comparison between the set width that is
based on eminent that we used in most of
our experiments and the set with student
model
the bottom line here the set fit mini LM
we see the speed speed up gaps are uh
the set fit mini LM is six times faster
and the score here is the average score
across all the data sets that Lewis
showed
uh here in the distillation setup for
the set with student we use the all of
the available unlabeled data that we had
so those unlabeled amount of
unleggled data uh and what we see here
is that the set feed student closes the
Gap we have only two uh false short in
only two points from the set fit empty
net
yeah that's it
great thanks a lot
um all right we have a question which is
maybe more General
um about said that which is could you
train end to end instead of on Frozen
embeddings
um so that's a really good question uh I
think the answer is yes
um we actually have a member of the
community uh implementing this uh in the
in the library so maybe in a week or so
um you'll be able to do this but um the
the sort of advantage of this approach
of having Frozen embeddings is that it
makes it uh you know a very simple thing
to to implement you just do this
iteration of fine-tuning
the sentence transform with contrastive
learning and then you just do the
standard classification head
um the advantage of using end-to-end
training is that we can then do more
interesting things for like optimized
inference so if we want to export the
model into Onyx or something and then
quantize it then it's a little bit more
convenient if it's just a single neural
network end-to-end but let's see um you
know how we go with that
okay so I thought what we could do now
is we could segue into a little example
with some code just to show you how this
actually works in practice
and if you go to hugging face set fit on
GitHub
um we have a little library that kind of
implements this
and what I want to show you is if you go
down to the notebooks folder we have a
couple of notebooks showing how you can
do standard text classification to hyper
parameter search to multi-label text
classification
and I'll just start by just going
through this test classification example
so here I'm just going to switch on GPU
so it runs a bit faster
um so we need to install set fit this
will take a few seconds
and um one thing that we we implemented
is an integration directly into the
hunger piece hub
um so if you're not familiar with the
hanging face Hub
um basically it's a hub for models data
sets and machine learning demos
and inside the separate Library we have
an integration where you can basically
download sentence Transformers from The
Hub and then you can also push your
fine-tuned sentence Transformer back to
the hub so you can then use it for for
other tasks
so
um what we're going to do when this
notebook is installed we're going to
just log in to our account this will
allow us to push the model to the hub
and the way you do that is on your
profile you can select
hey Lewis I'm sorry to interrupt again
but would you mind uh highlighting some
Steven's comment thanks thanks
sorry about that all right
so in order to push our model to the hub
we're going to need um a token so you
can generate that from your profile by
going to the settings
and when you feed this token into this
widget this will now essentially log Us
in to our account on collab so that's
just a little detail that we need to set
up when we're running from collab and we
also need to do a little bit of git
stuff here I'm just going to put my
email address
oops
and my name
so please don't send me tons of spare
mail
okay so what we'll do today is we'll um
do just a simple binary classification
on the sst2 data set
and we're going to use
um the mpnet model that we used in our
paper this we found was a good
all-rounder
so the way we can get this data set is
using the low data set function from the
data says Library this will basically
pull from the hiking page Hub the sst2
data set
and you can see here in this example
we've got things like
um a bunch of sort of sentences and then
they're kind of labeled you know
positive or negative and this is
um some sort of Fairly you know popular
academic Benchmark extracted from so the
idea is you know how well can we
classify these sentences using just a
small number of examples
so the first thing we're going to do is
just create a kind of simulated few
short data set so you know in this case
the training set has 67 000 labeled
examples and the idea we want to do is
just say okay if I just select eight
examples that are positive and negative
um how well can we do
so I'm just going to do that using
um you know a little bit of shuffling
and slicing from data sets so now we've
got a training data set which has 16
examples eight for positive and eight
for negative
um and we'll use now the like the full
validation set
um uh to sort of measure how well our
model is doing I think in reality you
know you wouldn't have like the full
validation set which has 872 examples in
reality you know in the real world
you've only got a number of labeled
examples and so there you might have to
think about things like you know how do
you define your evaluation in a way that
is not too noisy
um and there's actually a question here
does it matter that your classes are not
balanced
yeah so
um I think in this case I'm just trying
to simulate a small example of few shot
uh
um data set
um in practice probably there is a
little bit of a
question of like should you stratify
your sampling and in the in the paper
um the sampling we used was a little bit
more sophisticated
I would say that in those cases where
you have imbalance
um probably the best thing to do is to
just make sure you're not using accuracy
as your metric uh pick a metric like F1
which is a little bit less insensitive
to the imbalance
um but yeah you can do a slightly more
sophisticated sampling if needed
Okay so we've got a data set now
um and it's going to be pretty simple to
train the model we basically uh we use a
from pre-trained method so if you're
used to using Transformers it's the
basically the same API
we just specify a model ID on the Hub
which in this case
is uh symptoms Transformer so we go to
sometimes
um Transformers and then it's probably
paraphrase mpnet okay or it's one of
these very similar like this
and you can see you know this is a model
on the Hub which has got some sort of
model card and how to use it and we're
just going to download the weights into
our notebook
and then initialize this uh with both
the sentence Transformer body and the
classification head
and the first time you do this you'll
get some kind of warning that the model
head was not found in the hub
um and that we're going to initialize it
with random weights so you know you
should train this model on a downstream
task and that's because at the very
start when we create the safety model
we're just taking the pre-trained
sentence Transformer and the the head
and neither neither of these have been
trained for set fit so what we need to
do is do first the contrasted learning
and this classification head
so
the way we can do that uh kind of
quickly is using a trainer so we have a
set fit trainer class where you provide
a model you provide the data sets you
want to train and evaluate on
um and then you can specify the type of
loss that you want to use for
contrastive learning so one of the
things that we investigated in in our
analysis was like what effect
um you know does the type of loss have
on the final performance because in
contrasted learning there are like
different losses that have been proposed
over the years for how you measure
essentially distance between your your
positive and negative samples and we
found that the cosine similarity Works
quite well there are more sophisticated
things like triplet loss or subcon loss
but in in general you know we found that
there's not a huge difference between
using them versus the simple one of
cosine
and then the other thing is the number
of epochs so this is essentially the
number of ebooks we're going to use for
contrastive learning
um that's a parameter we found just
generally one Epoch does quite well
and then the number of iterations here
indicates how many times we're going to
sort of do the sampling process to
create our kind of
um you know augmented data set because
if you think about what we're doing in
set fit if we go back here
[Music]
um
when we do this sentence generation
we're sampling a number of times from
the list of available texts that we have
and that those number of iterations is
kind of a hyper parameter that we can
tune we found that generally you know
doing this generation 20 times gives a
pretty good results
um but you can also use the hyper
parameter search functionality to find
the best one
so
the last one is that um uh in uh in
sentence Transformers or the way we've
implemented this we kind of expect that
your text and label columns are
normalized with a common name so
generally we expect your text to line a
text column your labels to lie in a
label column and if they don't in the
case for example if you look at an
example of
um
so in the case of sst2 all of the techs
are living in a sentence column then
this column mapping here can be used to
sort of align those essentially relabel
your columns so that it will work out of
the box
so now we've got a trainer uh we can
train it
and um this is uh gonna you know
probably take maybe 30 seconds or
something let's see how we go
um so this is essentially using um these
like 640 examples now with these that
we've augmented through this uh sentence
generation step and that's now trained
the model
and we can then evaluate it and see how
well this is
let's see Okay so we've got around 67
accuracy
um using just eight labeled examples per
class
now in general this isn't going to be as
good as uh training you know the full
model
um on
um on the 67 000 examples so for example
I think if we look here
um do we have performance somewhere
this model so yeah if you if you train
for example distill but you're going to
get something like 91 percent
um however that just to give you you
know this is a huge orders of management
difference in label data so if you have
you know more than eight labeled
examples you can then bridge that cap by
simply applying set fit on this way
and then the last thing to show is um
you can push the model to the hub so
um you know you can say set fit
uh fine-tuned on sst2
and if we push this to the hub
it will now create a repository on the
Hub under your account and then you can
use that for imprints um you know in
your own applications so collab takes a
very long time
to to actually push things
um but while that's happening we've got
to kind of organizational interesting
question from Chris so maybe I'll just
put that here for Moshi so how did the
hanging pace and Intel collaboration
come to be you mentioned that my studio
first had the idea so yeah maybe
Marshall you'd like to talk about that
yeah with hiring Fest we have a long
history started something like four or
five years ago when we had the NLP
architect Library
then we have some research collaboration
with again face started a few years ago
and um yeah with set faith is it's it's
quite uh was quite nature intuitive to
to continue and and work together to
validate that fit uh for many uh data
sets so we just uh since we are already
had some established some collaboration
we continue to collaborate on sets it
was quite nature
um
yeah
and uh maybe an interesting question is
how did you get the idea of set fit I
think what inspired you I think from uh
yeah
from from the image uh domain they have
a similar approach that they use uh
contrastive learning to do uh I think
they are original paper from co uh
something like in 2015 he had a similar
approach for a One-Shot classification
so I think that and when you know it was
and I actually was familiar with the
expert sentence Transformer Library
which was actually quite amazing how to
do the uh in just two three lines of
code you are doing a full fine tuning of
Samsung Transformer so no one plus one
was actually yeah it was quite obvious
that you can actually and I think
something like uh 20 minutes I actually
won the first set feet on on ssd2 so
it's uh it's quite easy and when you
have expert it's very easy uh to
implement uh sentence Transformer and
fine tuning so it says what what's uh
obvious
yeah
great thanks so we have a question here
from dorea which is does set bit work
with all transform models
so I'm not sure about all but um
generally speaking if you have something
like an encoder
um base model then uh set fit will be
compatible with it
um but to be more specific essentially
if you go to the hooking Pace Hub and
you pick under the models tab
you can select for different libraries
so here you've got Transformers and
things like this if you click on
sentence Transformers you'll get you
know 771 different models ranging of
different sizes different pre-training
data sets
and generally speaking a large number of
these models will be suitable
for for set fit so for example you know
the mini LM one is the one that um RN
was talking about so it's very small and
compact you can also use the
multilingual ones and so on so my
suggestion would be to check out the
sentence Transformers list of models and
then just you know try different ones
there
um Neil's Reimer who was part of this
collaboration as well
he's also the creator of symptoms
Transformers and he actually has a
really nice
um table on his documentation where he
shows like all the different pre-trained
models and how they kind of uh perform
from an embedding perspective so you can
see here like you know which model gets
the best score on sentence and bettings
and what's the average performance
what's the speed and you can kind of
filter this for like a high a very large
range of like models that he's created
and so personally what I do is I
actually look first on on niels's
documentation to see you know what's a
good model that seems to get good
performance and is not too large
and then um using that uh you've got a
good start
um
okay and so
we have maybe time for a few more
questions
so
here's one which I think is something we
didn't solve which is uh how to overcome
the sub token limit of the base models
to classify longer documents
so I don't know if uh if you ever did
experience in this case Moshi but my
understanding is that
um you know because we're essentially
doing sentence Transformers then we we
sort of truncate the long documents uh
to you know whatever the the context
sizes
um
okay
so let's just have a quick look at if
this model has finished okay so as you
can see collab is extraordinarily slow
six minutes to push three 400 Meg it's
um it's gonna take us a while
um so while that goes I'll answer a few
more questions
um
here's a question I don't know the
answer to can we compare set fit to
other episodic based models like
matching it or protonet
do you have any ideas
um
yeah I I know that um in a lot of these
like parameter efficient approaches
um people use things like these
prototypical networks to try and get
better performance but I'm not totally
familiar so if you want to you can
clarify a bit
um another question we have is
um from Alexander did you experiment
with longer multi-sentence text as well
um yeah so we we did
um if we look at um the summary results
here
um
here we've got for example Enron spam is
a sort of spam classification data set
and it's got very long emails so here we
truncated things to 256 tokens
um so a few paragraphs but you can see
that you know the difference it's the
set that still does quite well
um and is still better than our standard
fine tuning
um with things like Enron spam also AG
news has a relatively long text and see
if it does quite well
um so yeah in general the length of the
the text uh doesn't play a huge role
unless of course you're dealing with
very long text classification tasks in
there you know set fit might need to be
kind of combined with other techniques
like you know sliding Windows over the
document to chunk it into smaller pieces
for classification okay
foreign
and
great the model's gone to the hub and so
if we now check it out we've got a set
bit model here under my account
and this now means that if you want to
use it for inference we can just uh use
the from pre-trend method again
um from set fit and then this will
essentially load the model in a very
similar way to the Transformers pipeline
so you just provide a list of texts and
then this will generate the predictions
and so
spoon when this uh downloads we'll then
see what comes out
and
you ask questions
there's an interesting question here
from Bimal which is could one use this
kind of techniques with like clip
embeddings
so that's kind of an interesting
question in a sense of like whether you
can combine text encoders with uh you
know resonance to to get like maybe
better kind of search semantic search
but I'm not sure about image
classification have you thought about
that combination
interesting
so yeah I don't think we've uh thought
about that but that's definitely
interesting thing to look at
and then um just to see how we go okay
so the model has now predicted one and
zero for these input texts and okay in
this case perhaps they're a little easy
but it's pretty clear that you know you
shouldn't add pineapple to your pizza
and the model got that right so
um low down safely
um okay so I think maybe we can uh our
sort of time this up but um if there's
any sort of like last uh burning
questions we can take them in the chat
I think we have a an interesting one
here from Dennis which is how would this
work for Toby classification
um so yeah this is indeed work in
progress we don't know the exact answer
um and the the kind of challenge here is
that with um in in the text
classification case right we were
talking about
um kind of clustering the embeddings
according to their classes in the future
space and this is like instance based
classification where you take the full
example and then it's just a single
embedding in the token classification
case it's uh trickier because now
instead of just having like a single
embedding for the for the input we now
have multiple embeddings right one for
every token and there is work uh
previous work on on trying to figure out
how you do like few short term
classification again using different
types of Transformers
um but uh yeah we're still trying to
figure out if we can do this uh kind of
more efficiently than what is currently
done
okay
and maybe the last question from Chris
is what's wrong with pineapple and pizza
um
I I think the answer is of course
everything everything is wrong
yeah so maybe with that um are there any
final words
we would like to share
of where the community will continue to
expose that fit for other tasks I think
it's uh also quite interesting to see
how we can use unlabeled data to improve
performance
even for the text classification use
cases and also apply to other
tasks like two sentence classification
and also trying to think about
not just topics maybe full documents
classification and more than that so
they're really
many opportunities I hope to see more
results from the community
yeah great great point and um if you
want to contribute for example new
applications you're more than welcome to
open an issue or pull request on the
circuit library and myself or someone
else in the team will um we'll respond
so aren't any last words
uh no thank you everyone
thanks thanks for the great
collaboration hope the community will
continue to contribute into it it's very
exciting to see if you shot working
in the real world
yeah and if people find nice use cases
or where simply it worked well and you
know especially around deployment uh
please feel free to share them with us
we'd be very excited to hear
um both where it works and where it
doesn't so we can you know make it
better
so with that I'll uh in the broadcast
thank you everyone for chiming in uh we
hope you learned something new and uh
yeah till the next event
catch you later
bye everyone